[Music]
the best thing society can do is set a
bold goal and think about how to achieve
it and go for it I just love that idea
of governance of course I grew up with
it
President Kennedy in my youth said to
the Congress in 1961 that's how old I am
and I remember those days he said I I
believed that America should adopt the
goal before this decade is out of
landing a man on the moon and returning
him safely to the earth
President Kennedy said we have a big
goal let's go to the moon and back and
let's do it this decade and you know the
engineers and the scientists said that's
pretty cool and the Congress said that's
something good for us to invest in and
within the decade of course Neil
Armstrong walked on the moon and we had
a transformation of space science of
communications technology of
semiconductor capacity of computation
that were all spin-offs of that
wonderful adventure now I know that when
President Kennedy said that there was no
plan for how to do it and everything had
to be built along the way and everything
was learning by doing and everything was
boldness and risk-taking and putting
resources into it but they had the goal
they had the self-confidence they had
the idea that this great challenge would
be an inspiration would organize our
energies and would have fantastic spill
overs like global communications like
GPS like computation like the
semiconductor industry so that's
optimism but optimism connected with
goals connected with the clear thinking
with rationality with ways forward with
the the boldness to say we can do great
things
I believe we absolutely should have such
bold goals for our country
by 2030 let's cut the poverty at least
by half by 2030 let's cut the inequality
in our country decisively so it's like
the northern European countries not like
this god-awful inequality that we have
in the United States by 2030
let's move decisively to renewable
energy these are all achievable goals if
you can land a man on the moon between
May 1961 in the summer of 1969 don't
tell me we can't transform our energy
system to save the planet of course we
can so this is what optimism is but
optimism linked to clear goals timelines
and good rigorous thinking and
mobilization of people that can help to
lead and can help society to get the job
done
[Music]